JAMIE OLEKSIAK AT THE POINT.
SAILS FROM THE WALL.
REESTABLISHES BACK FOR LARSSON.
HOUNDS IT AND HE HAS IT.
HERE'SE WILL
PASS, DOESN'T CORK.
AND TOMASON.
>> WELL, BY
DRIEDGER. IN SANICE, HE LAY OFF,
YOU HAVE A MOVING SCREEN IN
NTER.
MOVE IT.
ON THE SPOT.
SEATTLE STARTS THE BREAK OUT.
THIS IS GO STOLEN AND HE
WILL DANCE.AST
SECOND.
>> McCANN, AND SOUCY, AND EBERL.
NICE READ BY OLEKSIAK.
HERE COME THE KRAKEN.PLAY IS TO.
OVER TO LARSSON FOR A  J.T., PI
FOR SAN
ONE OF TWO GOAL SCORERS TONIGHT
FOR  NICE SHOT FROMR ATTACK.
AND GOOD FORCE THER BE OF ESTEE
KUHLMAN.
LARRSON, McCANN.
OFF THE GOAL I, PLAYS IT BY BUR
MARIO
AL AY BACK. QUICK SHOT
HOFF.
AND WENNBERG, AOVES ALONG.
SHOT TAKEN.
KAHKONEN, THE BY
BONINO.
OUT IN FRONT, THERE'S OF THE CO.
MARCHING OUT IS TIMO MEIER.
HERE IS BARABANOV, WITH SPEED,
HEVLASIC.
BACK AND GETTING IT TO   BENIER.
DROPPING IT BACK TO